foreign
Michigan to Grand Rapids and talk to the
great and wonderful Carrie what's up
Carrie
hi Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call of course how are you this
morning I I could not be better I'm
doing great doing great so what's up hey
um so I have a situation my my husband
is suffering from anxiety and depression
and it's been affecting me and our
five-year-old son
um he really refuses to talk about it
um he just kind of brushes off
suggestions to get outside help
and
um I just don't know how to support him
I don't know what I can do to help
but it's gotten to the point where you
know I just I don't want to live this
way any longer especially if he's kind
of shutting everything down and not
wanting to address it
my
um
my heart's broken because my wife could
have been the one that made this call
I've been there on the other side of
this thing and so I get it
I also get you have to take care of
yourself
you have to take care of that little one
and it can feel like
um one thing I didn't get especially
initially
is that there's a lot of you looking in
the mirror saying what is it about me
that isn't good enough for him to go get
the help he needs what is it about our
kid
that isn't a big enough deal he's gonna
go get the help he needs
Hackley yeah those those questions will
drag you underwater right
yeah well I have a little bit of
background okay on this and I think that
it started I'm not sure but
um so less than a month of us uh dating
uh we've actually we've been together
about 18 years and married for 11.
um less than one month into US dating
his mom was murdered overseas
wow and he did not take any time off
work he stayed as busy as he could he
was overtime tried to find projects to
do around the house
um we have reason to believe that his
brother had something to do with that so
of course you know he's kind of lost
that relationship too
um but now he's I I believe that he's
still using being busy as a coping
mechanism
and we feel like we're in his way
um
constantly just on the go on the go on
the go
yes
you may have heard me say my buddy uh
Ian Simkins
um
gave me a great line one time said that
if if busyness is your drug then rest
will feel like stress yes that
sadly kicks in
um weekends are very hard for us yeah
because it throws us off for a normal
routine
um it feels like you're married to uh my
wife described it she said it was like
being married to a taser
yes it was just electric and if I said
anything
she's like I obviously I've never hit my
wife I didn't scream I wasn't loud or
anything but she said if I said
something it just came back so electric
that I just
found it easier to say nothing it's just
safer to say nothing
and then he feels that disconnection
which makes him go to the only thing he
only drug he knows which is work more
which then pulls him further away and
then just getting this this cycle so let
me let me tell you this I'm gonna tell
you exactly what helped in my life okay
I'm gonna give you the Playbook that
that ultimately
pulled me out of this mess and saved my
life and
um may not work for everybody my life
isn't everybody's life
um but it's the best road map I got okay
okay number one I want to avoid the Trap
of saying everybody Grieves in the same
way and I really fell into this early on
okay I would tell old grizzled ranchers
you need to spend some time crying and
that was wrong they didn't
their bodies metabolized trauma
differently than mine did it just did
and so there's not a right or wrong way
for this to look and so I want to look
move the the way that he quote unquote
should be grieving his mom the way he
should have grieved his mom I want to
move all that to the side
the second thing I want to move to the
side is any sort of clinical Diagnostics
has he ever gone to a psychologist or
medical doctor and been diagnosed as an
anxious and and it was some sort of
depressive disorder some type of anxiety
disorder
no okay I want to move all Diagnostics
off to the side
okay let's move them over there let's
stop using the words anxiety stop using
the words depression those are clinical
terms that's like saying you got the flu
or you've got some sort of infection and
you need to get antibiotics I'm not
taking antibiotics you really don't know
so let's move those things over to the
side
I want you to
so we got those over the side so here's
what you can do okay number one this is
going to sound nuts and I know you're
going to think all right idiot I've
already tried this
but this isn't a one and done thing I'm
talking about this as an ethos okay as a
way of being in your body's alarms are
going to ring off the hook
the only time I would tell you don't do
this is if he is abusive either verbally
or physically okay is it either of those
two things
no okay cool I want you to create a
posture of leaning towards him not away
okay here's what that looks like when he
walks in the door everything in your
body says get out of the room
I want you to go towards him
when um he's sitting down at the table
kind of like that my wife called it the
Sunday afternoon bear there's just a
bear in the living room and we just know
to avoid it
I want you to go sit by him
real close
make him tell you to move
because I'm telling you he probably
won't
if he does now you have an Avenue we got
to deal with some bigger issues here
okay
and okay so we're gonna lean in instead
of pulling away number two I want you to
start calling a spade a spade
what do I mean by that
honey you cannot disappear when I bring
our son into the house
that's different than your anxieties
driving us crazy
I want you to be very specific about the
things he is doing in the house that is
causing you and your son and your home
to not be whole
because when you take a doer when you
take somebody who's obsessed with whose
drug is being busy
and you say I need these specific things
at first those become tasks to check off
and what he'll find is
my wife leans in a lot closer when I'm
helping around the house
and when I'm quiet
and when I'm exhaling in his body his
nervous system will begin to respond
before his head does his head will be
like oh it's so annoying I'm going to do
the dishes on top of everything else I'm
doing
yeah body will relax
okay here's number three
okay I did not know this had happened
but my buddy I we had my son Hank I
think he was two
um maybe he was 18 months old
one of my best friends on the planet
Todd he had had a little boy and him he
called and he's like hey me and my wife
are coming to bring our kid over he
lived about three hours away I'd moved
away after college and um we're gonna
bring our little boy over so our boys
can meet and you can meet my son and I
want to meet your son all that I was
like that sounds great
and when he came over I spent a couple
hours with him talking about everything
about this and about this and what about
this and the economy is going to do this
and my house is falling apart here and
all this I went all all in
he was my friend and I vomited all over
him and he walked around the house with
me looked at all the problems and I'll
never forget this we were out on my
driveway
and he looked at it and you got a
picture of this I'm a wild haired just
loud mouth guy and I've calmed
down a lot over the last decade I was a
mess and he is this he's had the same
haircut since he was zero years old
um he tucks his shirt in to go to bed I
think
um he's just like a straight lady he's a
banker he's just as straight as could be
okay
um everything's lined up
and
he had his hands in his pockets and he
listened to me and listened to me and
listened to me and listen to me and then
he finally looked at me and said hey
your house is good
this conversation is over we're not
having it anymore
and you need to go get yourself checked
out
and that was the first time in my life
when he left
I thought the first time I thought it
may be me
because I trusted that guy
and I came to find out later my wife had
called him and said I'm really worried
about John and I don't know what to do
and he had said I'll come down and talk
to him and he brought his family I'm
getting all choked up just thinking
about it now he took a day off of work
and drove down to see me
and so it may be that you reach out to a
friend of his one or two of his buddies
who love him
and she's since done that again and it
was really important
in fact when I was writing this last
book she called two of my she called
Todd and another one of my friends John
and they flew down to see me here in
Nashville
and after that I went and checked myself
into a hotel and after that I went and
checked myself I went and got with a
trauma counselor and started some real
healing it was really important but it
started with my wife saying okay he
listens to these men in his life he
needs to reach I'm going to reach out to
them and it wasn't a violation of my
trust it was her saying I love you and
this guy needs some oxygen and those
guys have oxygen from my husband
and so number three is reach out to
somebody that might be able to get
through it to him in a way that you
can't
okay okay
but I want to throw away the um the
clinical language be very clear and
specific and ultimately the conversation
with my wife that changed my life was in
our backyard in a couple of folding
chairs it wasn't any Grand thing
and I said I feel like you're creating a
life without me and she said I have to
because you're not okay
yeah
that's exactly what has been happening
with us okay
um we there's so many things that I have
done by myself with my son I've I've had
to take him out as a home
um and just do things on our own we've
have you told your husband that
yes and he knows okay
um
we've gone to Holiday you know dinners
at relative's house and he stayed at
home we've you know we've gone to have
you said the words to your husband in a
private conversation
I don't want to do my life alone anymore
I want you by my side
um
no okay not not exactly in those words
here's the deal Carrie you have to be
that specific and here's why I know
here's why I think you're crying why
it's terrifying because he might say no
he might say I'm not doing it
but if you're like hey are you going to
this dinner hey do you want to come play
soccer with us hey you want to go out to
the to the market with us he's always
going to say no
that anxiety is too strong the
depression's too strong whatever's going
on in his heart and mind is too strong
but if the woman he loves and the mother
of his son sits down in front of him and
says I'm tired of doing my life by
myself I need you by my side
whatever it takes for you to get well
I'm all in but I'm not doing my life by
myself anymore or I'm going to do it all
by myself
yeah when I don't want it I don't want
it to come to that I know Carrie but
you're there
and here's what happens inside this
house
you start creating your own life he
knows it his body feels it and he
doesn't know what to do and so what does
he do he just does his drugs which is
work more and work more which makes you
have to do more of your and you just all
of a sudden you wake up and you're five
years later and you're sitting on the
couch next to him and you're six inches
apart but you're six thousand miles away
from each other
yeah right yes I felt that before I know
I know I know
here's the deal you've heard me say this
on the show this is about turning all
the lights on turning the music off
and saying the life we are co-creating
together ends today
will you build something new with me
and you have to be ready for him to say
no I won't
and hopefully that's vulnerability right
When You're vulnerable like it's a cool
buzzword but you can get hurt when
you're vulnerable
but I want to tell you you're getting
hurt now
you're getting hurt now you're slowly
drowning
that's exactly what it feels like yeah
and I feel like it's not fair it's not
very fun it's not gonna absorb absorbs
everything and
Carrie it's not fair to you either it's
not fair to your husband it's not fair
to anybody
yeah okay don't just do it for your son
do it for your husband do it for you do
it for this thing called marriage this
thing y'all are building together
I strongly recommend you don't do this
on the back end of a fight tell them
I want to have a long conversation
um I always tell people it kind of
turned into a joke around here like a
meme around here but I always tell
people to go to breakfast because it's
early in the morning and it's sunshine
you know outside sometimes
um and once people get to like nine
o'clock there's no more productive
conversations happening you can have a
bunch of deep philosophical mumbo jumbo
at two in the morning but good deep
conversations happen when everyone's
brain is clear and so I recommend get a
babysitter for your son and take your
husband out and say I'm taking you out
um
and we have to talk about some big
picture stuff
okay
um stay on the line here I'm gonna send
you a copy of I'm gonna send you both
books one is own your past change your
future and that is about okay we're in
Ash what do we do now
how do we get here and then what do we
do now and then my newest book Building
A non-anxious Life That's a book you and
your husband can read together about
building a completely new life
and there's some choices y'all can make
every day every week every month about
building something completely new
it will involve him getting the help he
needs but I want to tell you someone
who's been there it took me
a year with a guy named Randy and a guy
named Slade two guys that kept showing
up for me one guy in the weight room
then we'd go to lunch it took me that
long and then it took me getting a new
job
and then it took me getting some new
friends into some confrontations before
I ever went and saw a counselor I didn't
just race right into it I didn't I
didn't have that kind of Courage I
didn't even know the words to say
and then I got around some more friends
and some more it was a long long walk
but I got healthier and healthier and
healthier as I went and then I had some
big blow ups almost blew my marriage up
kept going kept going kept going
okay so this isn't just a one and done
deal this is a journey y'all are heading
on your husband's been through hell and
back and you've been by his side every
time
it's time for you to stop getting
dragged behind the boat though
take ownership of your life of your son
of your home turn the lights on
stop the music
and let them know the life we have
co-created up until now this one's over
I want to build something new
something where we're doing this
together
I hope with everything I have that
you'll join me in this
I want to do this with you
carry call anytime I'll be with you
every step of the way call anytime let
us know how that conversation goes we'll
be rooting for you and if he wants to
call me I'd love to talk to him I'd love
to talk to him
foreign